since its inception filmmaking has been
a space of potential danger in fact it's
often the films with seemingly the least
amount of risk that pose the greatest
danger to the actors from beloved kids
movies to classic 90s comedies these are
the surprising scenes that were actually
dangerous to film
children and adults alike have loved the
wizard of oz since its release in 1939
but beyond the bright technicolor world
was a land of danger accidents and
poison the production of the wizard of
oz has become as legendary as the film
itself due to its many unfortunate
mishaps the wicked witch of the west was
accidentally set on fire when a trapped
door malfunctioned during a scene the
tin man got poisoned by his aluminum
heavy makeup even terry the dog playing
toto wasn't exempt as one of the winky
guards accidentally stepped on her paw
and broke it but surprisingly one of the
most dangerous moments of all was the
poppy field scene the cowardly lion tin
man and scarecrow stand above dorothy
who lies unconscious among the poppies
as snow starts falling around them turns
out things weren't so gentle the fake
snow was made of asbestos a toxic
carcinogen the dangers of asbestos were
known by the early 1900s but that didn't
stop producers from dousing judy garland
and her co-stars with it now my beauty
something with poison in it i think
with poison in it
in spite of its name greece didn't run
quite as smoothly as producers had hoped
the film's climactic racing scene called
for john travolta and dennis stewart to
splash through water that was stagnant
and filled with bacteria also jeff
conaway slipped and fell while doing a
take of grease lightning leading to
lifelong back pain and an addiction to
opioids ultimately it was the prom
sequence however that proved most
dangerous to film on screen viewers can
enjoy a vibrant scene of bright colors a
dance-off and even john travolta doing
the splits but off-screen things weren't
quite so fun the los angeles gymnasium
where the dance was filmed didn't have
any air conditioning and doors were
closed to control lighting the location
got so hot a cool and casual 116 degrees
that several members of the cast had to
be helped off the set due to heat
related illnesses
while the standard for filming on
location in the middle of a city is to
close down the streets that isn't always
available when you're working on a
limited budget such was the case for
john schlesinger director of midnight
cowboy in the film jon voight plays a
sex worker who strikes up an unlikely
friendship with dustin hoffman's razzo
rizzo the most famous scene of the film
was an accidental one that almost
injured hoffman since production didn't
have the money to shut down the streets
they filmed voigt and hoffman walking
and talking in the middle of real new
york city traffic as they're exchanging
dialogue a cab driver tried to run
through a red light nearly hitting
hoffman this led to a genuine outburst
and a classic moment of film dialogue
1976's carry continues to terrify
viewers today with its stephen king
conceived tale of a bullied young woman
pushed to her breaking point the shoot
was intense as [ __ ] spacek was so
committed to staying in character that
she isolated herself from her castmates
slept in her bloody dress and even
insisted on being buried alive so she
could push her own hand out of the grave
in spite of all this it was the
climactic prom scene when carrie goes
after her tormentors that proved to be
the most dangerous with scenes like this
filmmakers have to plan carefully to
avoid mishaps but still things can
happen especially when a fireman refuses
to operate the fire hose because it's
too strong and a stuntman does it
instead pj souls who plays the bully
norma discovered this danger first hand
when she got sprayed in the ear with a
fire hose the power was so intense that
she suffered from a ruptured eardrum for
six months and the painful moment is
even included in the final cut of the
film
for the 40 year old virgin steve carell
decided to go full method not only did
he write the chest waxing scene for
himself but he also decided to get his
chest waxed for real while normally this
isn't so dangerous the stakes were
unknowingly raised with the hiring of
mickey mia who lied to the casting
directors about her waxing proficiency
so while corel perhaps anticipated some
level of pain what he didn't expect was
nearly getting his nipples ripped off as
mia didn't take the important step of
putting vaseline around that area the
scene proved so painstaking to film that
actor romini malco had to leave while
carell grinded his teeth and followed
through with the process the film's
director judd apatow loves to keep
things real and corel's agony was
extremely real in the end it was
definitely worth it at least for the
audience you know what guys
this is not a good look for me
the exorcist has become as famous for
its terrifying set as for its horror on
screen it got to the point that people
working on the film actually believed it
was cursed ellen burstin suffered a
permanent back injury while being yanked
by a harness several deaths have been
linked to the movie including cast
members and members of their families an
entire set burned down and a priest had
to be brought in to bless the set such a
physically demanding film understandably
has risks but one of the more dangerous
moments came as a result of the
director's head-turning scare tactics in
order to elicit the most authentic
reactions on screen william friedkin
would randomly shoot guns on set jason
miller who played father karas got into
an altercation with friedkin after he
fired a gun next to his ear to get a
surprise reaction miller noted that as
an actor he doesn't exactly need a gun
to be surprised or startled friedkin
never denied the claims of using a gun
to get a rise out of the actors in fact
he dismissed him because after all he
was only firing blanks
daniel day lewis is arguably one of the
most method actors of all time whether
it's spending an entire shoot in a
wheelchair for my left foot learning to
track and skin animals for last of the
mohicans or staying in a solitary prison
cell for two nights for in the name of
the father the man commits to a role
it's no surprise then that he got fully
into character to play one of his most
unforgettable characters violent angry
oil man daniel plainview in 2007's
critically acclaimed there will be blood
many remember the moment of day lewis
lecturing paul dano's character
i drink your
milkshake
but what viewers may not realize is that
this climactic scene was actually quite
dangerous to film ever the realist day
lewis insisted on throwing actual
bowling balls at dano who just barely
got out of the way the realism certainly
added to the moment helping create an
authentic and iconic film moment
an action series like the hunger games
requires a lot of safety planning due to
all the stunts but the most dangerous
and unpleasant scene to film may
surprise you while jennifer lawrence
made headlines after accidentally
kicking josh hutcherson in the head and
liam hemsworth heard his ankle while
filming mockingjay part 2 it was the
sewer scene that really put people in
danger in spite of having a sewer built
on a sound stage director francis
lawrence decided to do the scene on
location in a real sewer the water was
heated the ceilings were low which
wasn't ideal for the 6'3 liam hemsworth
and costumes got waterlogged adding at
least 20 extra pounds on top of the
actors plus being in an actual sewer
isn't exactly sanitary which led to a
quite miserable three-week shoot for
everyone but in the end they got the
footage and in the unique realm of
hollywood sometimes that need transcends
everything else
since its 1971 release willy wonka and
the chocolate factory has inspired the
dreams of countless kids and grown-ups
alike willy wonka's iconic chocolate
river in particular stands out as a
place of fun and fantasy but filming in
this candy wonderland wasn't quite as
wondrous as viewers might think
according to michael bolner who played
augustus gloop this dream was a bit of a
nightmare it was stinky water made of
150 000 gallons of water cream chocolate
and leftover coffee dumped by folks on
set the stench of the river only got
worse over time as the cream spoiled
during the course of the shoot bolner
had to do multiple takes spending the
day soaked in his smelly clothes each
take required him to go back up into the
tube where he was stuck with water up to
his mouth the filming of this scene was
so problematic that peter ostrom who
played charlie bucket noted that osha
likely had not approved such working
conditions
it's not just action films that can
prove dangerous for actors and extras
the physical nature of some comedies can
also create opportunities galore for
people to get injured which was the case
for mike myers and dana carby in wayne's
world who can hear queen's bohemian
rhapsody without thinking of the classic
scene from the first waynesworld movie
myers fought to have that song included
in the movie instead of the original
pick of guns and roses and it paid off
by becoming one of the most iconic music
scenes of all time according to myers
though it wasn't all fun and games the
guys in the mirth mobile got very into
the moment and director penelope spirus
needed many takes to get proper coverage
for all the various angles you see in
the scene as a result that scene took
almost an entire night to shoot leading
to some serious neck pain as carvey told
rolling stone in 2015 he was 36 at the
time and needed more than a few advil to
get through the night filming this
sequence might have been a headache for
the actors but fans everywhere had the
same reaction to the final scene
excellent
ishtar has gone down in film history as
one of hollywood's greatest bombs and
trouble plagued it from production to
release the 1987 adventure comedy stars
warren beatty dustin hoffman and
isabelle ajini and was filmed on
location in morocco what could go wrong
with a handful of warring egos intense
climate conditions and high political
tensions in north africa
actually a lot could go wrong and it did
the film became infamous for its
extravagant overspending and director
elaine may's high number of takes
perhaps the most dangerous scene was the
one where hoffman lies in the desert
surrounded by vultures in order to get
the large frightening birds to fly down
around him production placed raw pieces
of meat on hoffman's body just out of
frame hoffman asked are these vultures
going to know where the raw meat ends
and i start unfortunately for him he had
to do 50 takes to find out
the conqueror a 1956 john wayne film may
be one of the most surprisingly
dangerous films in history although you
wouldn't know it to see it in the early
years of the cold war the u.s created
the nevada test site and in 1951 started
testing its nuclear weapons due to the
winds the brunt of the nuclear fallout
was felt in st george utah when
producers of the conqueror decided to
film in st george they did so with the
assurance of the federal government that
the nuclear test site posed no hazard to
public health ultimately every scene of
the film that was shot in saint george
proved to be incredibly dangerous by
1963 director dick powell died of cancer
and by 1980 91 people from the
production 41
developed the disease some say that
wayne got cancer from this production
although the duke believed it was from
his six-pack a day cigarette habit check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]